okay so as you all know the song imagine
is the worst song ever written it is a
horrible horrible evil song it's not
just evil because it's pretentious and
ridiculous and the piano chords and all
of that it's an evil song because the
actual ethos that is promulgated by
imagine is completely idiotic imagine
there's no countries it's easy if you
try right okay so let's just be a little
frank about this right now it's pretty
obvious that our countries because every
single country on planet earth is
closing its borders to all of the other
countries and they talk about imagine
the lyrics II would imagine there's no
heaven imagine there's no Hell right all
we care about it's what happens here on
earth which of course would lead pretty
quickly to a moral breakdown of society
the song is just tremendously horrible
it's a horrible swamp without a horrible
immoral communist message I've talked
about it on the show extensively before
this is the single worst song in human
history I mean this sucker makes Justin
Bieber look like Beethoven this is it's
it's pretentious it's garbage II the
morality that it spouts is just spew its
moral spew it's worse than that
it's actually it's not just nonsensical
there's a sense to it there is a sense
but it's so deeply immoral and deeply
evil and yet it's put over this kind of
pretentious these long pretentious piano
chords and him singing meaningfully and
anybody who believes the crap in this
song anybody who believes the crap in
the song should never have any sort of
conversation with them it's a waste of
your time it's a waste of your
brainpower
[Music]
what he just said is the most immoral
thing you could possibly say hey imagine
all the people living for today that's
basically what we have okay imagine all
the people living for today means you
don't plan for the future it means you
don't care about your kids it means you
don't care what happens tomorrow it
means you don't care about anybody else
you just care about you okay this is the
most selfish morality possible if all
the people lived just for today they
would screw everything in sight and kill
all their enemies that's what would
happen if everybody lived for today
cause what happens tomorrow doesn't
matter if there's no punishment if
there's no reward and punishment in this
life or any other then all that matters
is what is good for me right now okay
it's a deeply immoral philosophy that's
being preached over this pretentious
garbage piano music I mean one of the
things I hate about the Beatles honestly
is I actually like trained musicians and
the Beatles I can write a melody there's
no question they can write a catchy hook
okay none of them knew how to read music
call me an elitist for me to call you a
great musician you have to know how to
read music okay I wouldn't call you a
great author if you don't know how to
read okay so this is oh but we'll
continue with this because there
actually is some substance and depths I
think this is the entire Democratic
Party I think this is the entire
American and European left I think this
is the more their morality in a nutshell
and I think they believe that it's
beautiful and it is the ugliest morality
that you could possibly conceive of
countries
[Music]
people
they're the next stands in there in the
no religion religion is the cause of all
the world's ills right communism an
atheist murdered a hundred million
people in the century he was writing
this they were busy murdering people in
China right as he was writing his
garbage okay this is this is such a
depraved morality there's no countries
there's nothing worth killing or dying
for really how about like the torture of
children is that worth killing or dying
for how about the murder of a hundred
million people is that worth killing or
dying for turns out that in your happy
Dappy a little land here where everybody
is is just wonderful enjoys this this
assumes a goodness of human nature that
just does not exist the left assumes
that all people inherently are good all
people are not inherently good and
anybody's ever met a child knows this
seriously children are innocent but
they're not good everybody assumes that
kids are good kids are not good kids are
selfish I love my daughter she's
wonderful but she wants what she wants
and if she doesn't get what she wants
she fusses and she cries and she lashes
out because she's a kid kids are just
baby humans right humans are all like
this humans are not all good and they're
not all bad they are capable of both
good and bad but mostly human beings are
not civilized that's why civilization is
necessary for human beings you have to
have cultures you have to have morality
that is taught if you just left
everybody alone in a field like in
primitive times everyone would kill each
other the murder rate in primitive
societies was enormous enormous and
nothing was developed because there was
no civilization and there was no
religion this sort of noble savage
nonsense that John Lennon was preaching
from the most highly civilized portion
of human civilization up to that point
in history it is amazing that all these
people live off the fruits of a
civilization that is absolutely contrary
to their values and then they suggest
that if they just rip away the
civilization then nothing will change I
mean honestly I should just dismiss this
because the guy married Yoko Ono I mean
that's that alone I should dismiss him
but but we'll go one more stanza of this
before I hurl myself through a window
let's let's finish up with John Lennon
imagine on the what was this summer when
when did he die gentlemen at 78
something like that I don't know it was
before my time but but we the ANA on the
anniversary of his death we're gonna
make fun of the worst song ever written
so here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
I hope so
[Music]
imagine No
here we go Tommy
in this giant house by the way while
standing in a giant dance house
[Music]
we need for greater hunger
never existed in ever will
imagine all
people
[Music]
this final push toward no possessions
honestly this is actually being promoted
by the left today and there's an article
in the nation yesterday yesterday je
Meyerson writing in the nation says we
should just abolish private property we
should just get rid of it because when
the Wampanoag the this tribe met the
pilgrims and they and the pilgrims had
claimed their land the Indians came
across the land and the pilgrims said to
them this is our land and the Wampanoag
said wait a second we don't do that sort
of like land ownership thing and JE
Meyerson says well weren't they right we
still don't have a good reason why is
why we shouldn't just share the land I
have a good reason why we shouldn't
share the land it's called several
thousand years of no human development
and then Western civilization that's why
we should we should not share the land
private property private property
ownership the idea of labor the idea of
owning what you produce is one of the
greatest goods ever discovered in the
history of civilization we would all be
one you know hunter-gatherer nomads
peoples with no history and we'd all die
at 30 if it weren't for human
civilization and private property
ownership and the incentive that
suggests that you own what you produce
but none of this makes any difference to
these people it's deeply immoral but
it's such a childish philosophy and it
bleeds all the way down to the kitties I
mean this really is something that you
would hear from a third grader but
leftist think it's so deep they think
stuff that seven-year-old say is just
the depth of what humankind is and it
really is evil okay you should not take
your moral advice from small children
you shouldn't but that's what this is
okay when my daughter is five I expect
that I'll probably hear this from her
and I'll have to inform her life isn't
fair and people do bad things right
those two premises alone destroy
everything John London is talking about
life isn't fair and people do bad crap
and as soon as you acknowledge these two
basic facts about the world none of this
makes any sense but I'm telling you the
entire left buys into this and this is
the happy world that would be if it
weren't for us evil Republicans and are
in our evil reality that we bring with
us it's it really is it really is quite
safe I know in which they each sing a
line from imagine because nothing says
solidarity quite like singing a no
borders idiotic communist song in the
middle of the pandemic in order to show
that you care also can anyone in
Hollywood like please come up with a
different idea for a video than
everybody's singing a line from a song
I'm not sure which is more
this or the version of fight song they
did in 2016 for Hillary I think it's
this I think it's this here's a little
bit of a variety of celebrities
demonstrating how emotionally deep they
are by singing the dumbest song ever
penned gal gadot easiest huge
[Music]
trying all these celebs imagine imagine
no countries Jimmy Fallon God is this
obnoxious garbage okay just stop it this
is the dumbest this is the dumbest song
ever imagine no religion in a time where
people are dying on mass imagine metal
again imagine no countries is a really
weird take when every border is shut
it's a very weird take like this is the
song that you choose I at least we are
the world had like a head like a
solidarity message that didn't include
the destruction of things that actually
prevent people from dying the
celebrities these are the people that
are moral betters we should listen to
Will Ferrell on this stuff singing a
minute like if this is the height of
your ethos Mark Ruffalo singing imagine
if the height of your ethos is the song
imagine it's because you're doing
morality wrong also policy only dumb
celebrities could come up with the
dumbest song ever and then sing the
dumbest song ever in order to promote
the dumbest agenda ever in the face of a
global pandemic that requires concerted
individual government action and again
significant restrictions on our way of
life unbelievable alright well but
perfectly believable because celebrities
are celebrities I hope you enjoyed that
clip from the ben shapiro show if you
did go ahead and hit the subscribe
button so you stay up-to-date on all of
our future content